because no one likes black lives matter
anymore it's very different from before
the chaven trial people were afraid when
we did the uh you know black lives
matter is a domestic terrorist
organization in antifa we did that in
austin people were shocked now most
people to varying degrees agree with
that sentiment that it's gotten out of
control and it's violent as a matter of
fact before i go because it was a
sentiment they agreed with until it
became an extremist group yeah well i
think it was founded as an extremist
group and people followed it not knowing
it's a little foreign
the destruction of the nuclear family
yeah yeah that's like if that's harder
that's your springboard you're going to
greg louganis yeah their manifesto is a
tough reason and your leaders are all
trained marxist and they say that yeah
so the polls now show that fewer
americans support black guys matter than
even in 2020. it was 61 percent in june
2020 48 percent now and of course we
know with those polls people tend to be
afraid they answer the yeah they either
answer in the way they think they will
get in the least amount of trouble or if
people are conservative they usually
just don't answer the phone what click